et voilà pour commencer ce tour du monde
des ponts garder un chiffre en tête 5
milliards de dollars ou environ ces
chiffres qui a été évoqué le montant qui
est évoqué pour le nouveau pont
champlain
il en a coûté 257 millions en chef de
2011 pour ce qui est du pont actuel
alors voyons commençons notre tour du
monde par le viaduc de millau en france
on voit ici donc le coup la longueur et
il est tellement haut que les nuages
passent en dessous c'est magnifique
c'est près de montpellier dans le sud de
la france
il a fallu tenir compte des vins plus de
200 kilomètres à l'heure et aussi de la
réalité sismique c'est le cas un peu
partout en europe c'est un pont à
haubans comme bien d'autres poursuivent
en maintenant avec celui ci qui relie la
partie sud et nord de rotterdam le pont
erasmus ou erasme 802 m comme on le voit
ici
et cet art qu'est magnifique hymne et si
on veut la forme du cygne de plus de 100
kilomètres de haut
voilà pour ce pont un autre exemple
poursuivants dont on peut se permettre
de rêver quand on regarde ceux ci ça
c'est le pari de l'audace c est donc
encore et du sud est pas encore achevée
c'est un pont qui sera en quelque sorte
habiter ce pas juste pour finalement
nous permettent d'enjamber un cours
d'eau l'assemblée nationale
un musée une bibliothèque les piétons
les cyclistes tout le monde pourra
circuler
voyez le coup voyez là donc la distance
parcourue par ce pont poursuivons avec
le suivant celui ci l'un en ce momment
dans celui ci le rayon attirions on it
l'engrais sa religion vue le péloponnèse
à la grèce dont continental on va voir
donc les caractéristiques de ce pont et
je vous dis une chose qui m'a frappé
personnellement sa religion veut deux
plaques tectoniques en mouvement ça
c'est tout un défi
il a fallu qu'il résiste que l'on
conçoive pour qu'ils puissent résister à
saigner un séisme de magnitude 7
voyez le coup et voyez donc que sa
longueur rappelons le 5 milliards que
j'évoque un peu plus tard pour le
nouveau pont champlain est maintenant
celui ci ça on est au portugal
c'est le plus long d'europe 17 km voyez
la forme qu'il emprunte voyez la
structure voyez la complexité aussi le
vasco de gama avec le coup qu'on voit
ici un peu plus d'un milliard de dollars
la particularité encore une fois ici les
vins plus de 250 km/heure et aussi la
réalité si s'miles encore une fois la
terre est sensible
donc de ce niveau leurs poursuivants
maintenant avec ce modèle ci qui était
sous milan revient chez nous là le pont
champlain mtq le ministère des
transports du québec a soumis cette idée
là c'est à dire d'un pont à deux étages
sarsat tournerait aux alentours d'un
pointe de 1.3 millions de dollars c'est
un peu ce qu'on a vu à hong kong avec ce
pont ici qui aussi à deux étages et donc
voilà ça permettrait les très léger
rapide de circuler des voix ici pour le
transport d'urgence et on l'a vu des
pistes cyclables sur le côté alors voila
si on veut un portrait des situations un
tour du monde des fonds pour vous est
d'alimenter ou vos rêves ou les
ambitions nous police je sais pour vous
donner c'est tellement député je vois ça
et je sais que ce matin c'était pas très
défi de m